We are the most self centered generation
in history,
not just the the generation that exists,
but the baby boom generation before it
was brought up in the me generation and
everything in society teaches.
It's all about me.
Every commercial says,
it's all about you.
We do it all for you.
Have it your way.
You deserve it.
I got to think of me first and we are
taught selfishness and that's why when I
wrote purpose driven life,
it's really a countercultural book
because the very first sentence is the
exact opposite of our culture.
It says it's not about you,
and that's almost like a slap in the
face.
No,
I'm sorry.
It's not about you.
There are a lot of things bigger in the
world that simply your own happiness,
your own fulfillment,
a your own little selfish.
Claude have a life as George Bernard
Bernard Shaw called it,
and uh,
the,
uh,
reasonably high divorces.
People don't,
haven't been given good models.
Their parents often.
We're a good model of unselfishness.
Second,
I think it takes three to make a
marriage work.
I think it takes you,
I think it takes your spouse and I think
it takes God.
It's like a three.
You can't have a two legged stool,
will fall over.
One legged stool,
will fall over two legged stool,
but when you have you,
yourself and and your partner and God in
the thing,
it makes a triangle and as you're
growing closer to God and your spouse
was growing closer to God,
it automatically brings you together.
My wife and I,
as I said,
are extremely different from each other
in practically every single way,
but as we grow closer to God,
we grow closer to each other and it is
the glue that has held us together.
When every bone in my body wanted to
give up on her body.
Now we actually made a commitment when
it was till death do us part,
and so we said,
we're going to lock this gay patch,
close it,
and throw away the key.
Now,
in those first two years when it was
hell on earth,
I mean really at.
We started fighting on the,
on the honeymoon,
and we're going,
wait a minute.
I saved myself for this is like,
what a disappointment,
you know,
and,
and we,
you know,
we were fighting from the first day on
because we were immature and we didn't
know how to share and how adults learn.
But as you grow through life,
uh,
if you stay with a commitment,
it really will get better.
It's,
it's being willing to learn,
being willing to reconcile a work.
Don't fix the blame fixtures.